une union des centristes dans les
yvelines le modem éludé y ont formé une
liste commune pour les élections
sénatoriales une alliance différente des
élections législatives lui d y était
allée au républicain le modem à la
république en marche
moi j'aurais souhaité faire une liste
d'union je pensais que pour un scrutin
comme les sénatoriales voilà ça avait du
sens de se réunir nous avons essayé
depuis plusieurs mois de faire une liste
commune avec la république en marche
il s'est trouvé que pour plusieurs
raisons ça ne s'est pas fait à notre
grand regret nous avons aussi plusieurs
fois de d'avoir des contacts et de nous
mettre sur liste commune ça ne s'est pas
fait
intitulé nos territoires au coeur du
projet national cette liste présente des
élus ancrés localement sur l'ensemble du
département des yvelines
chacun avec sa spécialité on retrouve
notamment laurent mazaury et georges
beliaïev deux élus centristes de saint
quentin en yvelines
ce qui m'intéresse sur cette liste c'est
justement la possibilité de
pouvoir travailler et faire remonter des
idées qui viennent du terrain et donc
pouvoir les exposer au niveau du sénat
avec un projet focaliser sur la commune
le but est de réconcilier les zones
rurales avec les territoires urbains et
des propositions en termes de finances
publiques locales
si on partage une grande partie des
réformes du président bak rond je pense
que notamment sur sur le volet fiscal
il faudrait que ce soit modifié je
préférerais qu'on repartira vrai pacte
fiscal et qu'on l'inscrivent dans le
marbre de la constitution de manière à
garantir aux communes les moyens de leur
existence tout en leur laissant aussi un
levier de fiscalité locale objectif pour
l'union des centristes obtenir au moins
deux sièges au sénat
face à eux onze autres listes les
élections sénatoriales se tiendront le
dimanche 24 septembre
[Applaudissements]